greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by let me ask you something have you
ever tried to shave your balls for a hot
date but accidentally ended up cutting
yourself uncle Joey here to tell you you
don't have to suffer no more right you
could [ __ ] trim your nutsack with
confidence with manscaped you can get it
done without the pain the anxiety you
know you're not gonna lose a [ __ ] nut
and be walking around like certain
people they got precision tools for the
family [ __ ] jewels ok
and you asked Dominique there's nothing
worse than going down on a guy and he
smells like 10 dead [ __ ] Iranians why
cuz ball sweat air whatever listen the
lawnmower point to is the handheld raise
it with the skin-safe technology this
bad boy will leave you clean smooth and
pain and anxiety free what I want you to
do is this right now the church family
can get 20% off your first order when
you use code church at manscape calm why
walk around with a stinky [ __ ] nut
sack and a stinky bug I've all that when
you could have manscape help you out so
right now go to manscape calm and use
promo code church for 20% of your first
order the church is also brought to you
by one of my all-time favorites zip
recruiter hiring is challenging but
there's one place you go where hiring is
fit simple fast and smart a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place its zipper cooler
dot-com slash church you're like Joey
why zip recruiter why I'll tell you why
because his applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match
zip recruit is so effective than any
percent of the employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day I don't care if your
business is small if your business is
large you want to save time you want to
get the right applicant go to right now
the church family for free I'll hook you
up with zip recruiter when you go to zip
recruiter comm slash Church that's right
the family gets to try zip recruiter for
free when you go to zip recruiter
dot-com
slash shirts ch you wash th zipper Cunha
calm slash Church kick this [ __ ]
mule Lee Thursday morning you're like
what the [ __ ] way you've been on me I'm
a busy
I've been busy making the [ __ ] happen
all right we got a special guest in the
house tonight my girl Domo what's up
Alex links she's an entrepreneur in the
adult business and she's gonna break
that on the future for you cuz I don't
know dick about porno so I'm I got a
little anxiety today plus she could be
my daughter so you're kind of nervous to
christ-killers in full effect
I'm an unofficial porn expert unofficial
but you've been watching it for [ __ ]
years I've been doing it so long
it leaves to have I was talking about it
this morning they used to have stories
written before when the internet was
terrible I think I used to read stories
I used to steal story
yeah they would write it out because it
was dialog and this is in this episode
Lina knocks on mmm ups is going oh yeah
they're different they're different
fetishes they did all that and then I it
my dad had a VHS tapes but there were
there were sort of amateur called
something uh debutante hmm and I used
the series it was a series a really
creepy looking guy and these amateur
girls but I would find I would remember
the time I would write down the timecode
of where the tape was and I watched it
when they were when my parents were gone
and them rewind it to where it was so
I've been doing it since god I probably
like middle school I would guess you
know it's just the porn that I watch as
a child that shocked me was so [ __ ]
disturbing and it all peep shows I like
they were just it's not I was raised
Catholic so I thought it was gonna be
rose I'm Catholic yeah yeah no no I
believe it I got nothing against [ __ ]
I'm just saying that you you I was
raised on this dream that you know and
you made love whatever you had this
weird feeling and and also I see this
chick that looks like she got run over
by a [ __ ] car twice
and they got a sucking dick on a porno
and she don't want to end the dick look
like he got VD was assembly and pimples
on it was and you know you don't know as
a kid and then I looked at and uh
growing up in New York they had a Puerto
Rican playboy that was just horrible
mm-hmm it was called pica pica horrible
it was a magazine with naked chicks but
their faces covered yeah it's like
chicks that would you know that somebody
tried to do shame over what everyone and
they took a Polaroid in those days it
was a Polaroid so it was just dirty
it was just dirty to a guy like me as
dirty as I am on stage and all that [ __ ]
it was kind of dirty and I just I went
as a child that was desensitized to
alcohol because my mother had a bar but
I was desensitized to pornography
because when I was like 16 a bar opened
in my neighborhood and the chick would
sit on a Galliano bottle you know the
[ __ ] yellow bow Galliano's in a sweet
Italian liqueur see if you get a
Galliano bottle on there you're gonna
take a look at this okay that was from
the hood I knew her brother I grew up
with her brother he came from an Italian
family where he was one boy and five
girls and one girl was hotter than the
other brunettes
Italian looking real pretty like you
this was a Galliano bottle and a
specialty was to sit on it it would be
at the bar
she would pull it out of the bar and sit
on the [ __ ] thing all the way to the
[ __ ] label in 1979 and then on
Wednesdays it was erotic banana night
and you would say you would pay five
dollars to get in they gave you two
frozen bananas and the girls would be
dancing and then you pull out like a
five and the girl would come from the
little stage and she would walk on top
of the bar walk over to you peeled a
banana
you gave the time she put the banana her
[ __ ] and she gave it back to you and
you been ate it and they give you
free shot of tequila disgusting thing I
saw Tom are you ready for the most
disgusting thing I saw that just [ __ ]
up my central nervous system there was a
guy sitting there like I won in there
one night alone my mother had died I was
living with a family I didn't want to go
to that house yet you know and deal with
that pain so this bar was on the walk
home listen didn't give a [ __ ] how old
you were Tom oh there was no like you
know they just talking legit there was
nothing and I walk him in one night
alone and I'm sitting at the bar and I'm
looking straight and I'm giving the girl
dollars and she's dancing I mean she was
this close yeah it was a thinner bar and
what it would be was would be an island
with a stage the bartender would be
there and on this side there would be
the booth or the bartender would have to
go around but the stage was here so if
you were lucky enough to be at the bar
she could come off from the stage and
you could touch a [ __ ] or grabbed her
titties or whatever so there's one man
up and then there's like a [ __ ] 60
year-old guy next to me I'm just
clocking him mmm
let's say 55 to 60 and he sitting there
I did not say a word that I guy I'm
sitting there drinking my [ __ ] gin
and tonic I look over at the guy and the
guy's got a [ __ ] dollar in his mouth
like a five in his mouth without no
communication the chick walked over
squatted put her [ __ ] in the face at
the final billa you could hear him
eating a [ __ ]
and then she backed away I put a finger
in her mouth and pulled out his teeth
and put him in her [ __ ] and then put
him back in his back
let me tell you so I just froze I came
everything that can happen yeah
everything that could happen do you
happen to me at that age like I said my
central nervous system went into shock
jack
you know I'd suck some titties I need
nobody's [ __ ] yeah I think I figured
girls and [ __ ] but to put a man's teeth
in your [ __ ] I'm gonna walking home the
press that night look I just [ __ ] my
world up like I'm gonna need therapy
somewhere along the line
so that was it happened then I got
desensitized like I know that was it
strip clubs weren't a big deal to me
they were just there was another one by
my house to cave if you looked at the
owner you just wouldn't go in there he
had to be 80 and he had a wig may not
like straw and they'll barely fit and
you could tell he made the girls
sleeping up in the horrible girls like
bullet wounds cesarean scar yeah like
they were missing a limb cut her hand
off
I mean this place is just disgusting
when you go in there it just wreath of
dirty [ __ ] like just the air of sweaty
you [ __ ] dead [ __ ] to died there
left in the corner to die like this was
the place that we went around this was
the place we went to like 22 to to get a
drink
just to torment do we would go in there
and spit on the floor and you know flick
at and then even come over to us yell
out this we time to go [ __ ] himself
and then he threatened us with the cops
and we believe we just go on to the
torture but that was it after that I
didn't have a strip club in my life till
1988
maybe I was born yeah never watched a
porn you know I either jerked off to
memory got somebody give me a stabbing
but there was no or no nothing I've been
huge
I later I was really I I've watched porn
for years I'm a big fan but I've I just
turned 30 thirty years ago and I still
haven't been in strip club
it kind of freaks me out why similar
what he was saying how you think it's
supposed to be nice but then I also and
I'm sure you don't cuz you're making
money hopefully but I always felt like
the girls but hate the guys who walked
in there like it felt true it just felt
like I I remember I went to school in
Boston and there was one in Chinatown
right next to my school there I walk
past at like lunchtime there
day and they were open noon who comes
here at noon when did you get I'm 29 I'm
gonna be 30 you think you're doing like
a weed store is this tough yeah I was a
bartender at a couple weed spots and
then I was a manager and then I was
training girls too but ten I was booking
girls at nightclubs dancing like 400
bucks you know but it we loved it and
and then I performed at festivals and I
kinda like reach my pinnacle of that but
it wasn't what kind of performing here
uh DC so we wore crazy-like costumes and
like LEDs and we were going on stage
with the DJ's like in front of 200,000
people so once you do that I mean it was
it's like this invincible feeling but
there was an amazing dance director she
was making these costumes being really
risque and kind of like futuristic and
we got these great pictures when we were
doing this is when MySpace and Facebook
just started coming I mean it was before
social media and stuff but oh my god it
was the [ __ ] awesome time like so I
wanted to take that into I kind of fell
into stripping and then I landed in the
porn scene now when you stripped uh-huh
how old were you when you first walk in
24 did you design your own outfits did
you give her back LuAnn oh yeah I took
what I learned from go-go dancing but I
mean I had to learn the whole stripping
etiquette how to dance it's a different
style dance and learn how to walk in the
heels and do pole and also hustle but I
loved it like it was you know it's in
Vegas it's 24 hours the club doesn't
close and there's people come in every
weekend it's money here and it's like if
I explain like the Vegas cuz I love
Vegas and I used to gamble oh damn
but I so I never did it but there are
guys on the strip who will give you a
free limo to the yeah club solo the
strip clubs they do that as a promotion
like to get people there and I mean uber
take some taxis but Friday Saturday it's
always poppin and I mean I dance in
spirit right now
so that's just my spot it's fun you can
have a drink there's different VIP rooms
there's you know you can dance it's
still kind of fun atmospheres there's
like 200 strippers hottest girls we have
the prettiest girls and they fly in from
all over yeah especially the first
Southwest flight in Vegas is amazing
it's people from around the world around
the world every [ __ ] they go there to
spend they [ __ ] hit the jackpot to go
there to go to a strip club Japanese
dudes Canadians yeah blending people
[ __ ] knew your old East Coasters
wasn't my best mask I'll know after how
long were you stripping when you got
into the adult business um I was
probably dancing like about like four
months and then I got into porn just due
to some complications and I had a lot of
friends in but I I did it really smart I
kind of went to my limits and um and I
learned like a lot I got you know I
dealt with one problem and then I was
all right whoa I saw how this gone but I
saw this cam world and I could've like
stayed in did my way for my own career
to do avians but I saw the Kami world
and I kind of went down and that way I
can help girls who aren't in the
industry you know girls that are gogo
dancers cocktail waitress whatever like
camming is really like open to anybody
like women are doing it when you say you
had your limits well it's important no
anal um I didn't want to
I mean that was a big thing was no anal
I wanted to make my own website and I
wanted to be a Dom I wanted to have have
a fetish niche and they were just like
oh you know what you're just you know
you should just not dye your hair red
and no more tattoos and I just went to
my hair and got more tattoos it was like
no [ __ ] you like you guys work from me
like I'm this is what I'm portraying cuz
I was like I wasn't dumb I wasn't going
in like I was some broken person like I
told my parents and everything but I
there was a style I wanted to go and
they would just always push me to things
I don't really want that forced you into
the camp yeah you said it didn't force
me and actually like I saw and I was
like well [ __ ] I already did this so I
can do this but I could do it in control
I can go to my limits and do like things
that I want to do that are actually fun
now you have a steady guy that you do
the cams with or do you pick and choose
different guy no no I do mostly solo a
mostly I perform with other girls okay
um if I I've you know thought about
bringing guys on but more so if I bring
guys on they're gonna be like my slave
[ __ ] and I'm gonna dominate them and
I'm gonna push it to towards that
element I'm pretty good on like boy girl
seems like I don't need to do that thing
we out and beat the photos absolutely I
mean a piece of [ __ ] those are my limits
I mean I'll do Playboy we're gonna have
to find some way with does because we
have to find helmet man am we getting
farther than we'll put some [ __ ]
xanax and a [ __ ]
right a for for two days if guys
constantly talk about things he has done
nothing for seven years except talking
about he wants I think you're scared to
it I think the audience no they don't no
one brought this up you brought it up
you this because I feel bad for you but
I think you need to to break all the
other things I don't leave he doesn't do
so many things or the next week new SEC
toast I'd rather start to toe than even
[ __ ] see it first because being like
a full giver and really just making them
feel so so sexy and how I was looking at
where [ __ ] comes out make them feel so
sexy okay you have to take care of mine
back because shit's not just always
there there it is always there no
actually when their mind is some it's
always there
well I'm telling you from a girl that's
like me well there's not wonderful
juices as wonderful juices north but
let's say you had a closed mind I do I
like very basic sense I want
I like regular stuff vanilla yeah sure
the last girl what's up with got me into
like hair pulling and choking a little
bit which is fun that's that's as much
as I like it the choking I actually kind
of did like a little bit but it is kind
of scary but uh yeah that idea I don't i
just the [ __ ] is disgusting prob to
me i'm understandable I mean thank you
Mike I can't eat guys ask you there but
yeah that's what I'll find somebody who
will how did you have eat some guy's ass
no never
see not even no no
Nonpoint I don't do that no no not in
the portal am I really okay we ate some
way McGivern what halfway there
there we go I'm fine with totally making
the girl feel real good see does it feel
good oh look if you don't suck some
woman's toes and see her reaction really
you're not living yes okay that is a
very like sacred set like there's a lot
of nerves in there so it's really
intoxicating oh can I just suck on that
Mexico pay for her pedicure so you know
that it's all clean and yummy hold on
one second
we need to let fence weeds in it tells
climbing your [ __ ] fence and you're
right there this side you gotta move to
Mexico before Trump goes to war you know
suck out a little Mexican right as
they're coming over the phone it's that
little Jew dirt on them that was the
Jewish diamond dealers have they always
had a little mud on their fingers they
say with a little African blood is there
a section for this on your site
different sites that have a fan base for
that what did I see here like the girls
that I've dated are like sooo like I I'm
vanilla but they're like extra vanilla
good I asked some girls that you'll meet
your [ __ ] knowing you're supposed to
turn them around like yeah he had a girl
that he dated for four years never came
in a month
oh because she wouldn't like it this
half of fact no you need it's on our
unit proteins you milk this is gonna
make your skin glow nope so are you guys
gonna spit my bail or how's it gonna
work out right now Jude milk
woman they wanna be [ __ ] pinned down
at home so you know what you're gonna
take dick thank you Jesus you never [ __ ]
you in the morning and you tell her I
like it so you need to be ready that
doesn't seem like it's not allowed just
take your panties off and eat that [ __ ]
and go gotta get in her head
none of them none of these chicks come
around the last one three bills I told
the either ass she had a big ass I go
put vaseline on your cheeks and go in
their head first because it's tough to
get in that ass we got a pink slip again
I'm Friday because she wanted you know
she wanted me to be her boyfriend and
itch means aka my ass just tell her what
she wants to hear the Mexican lived on
his house for a year didn't do nothing
rent-free he didn't come in the mouth
you didn't come in a ride boy nothing
they just kept buying Chinese food
they would walk together they broke the
zip line then he dated the I friend now
is dirtier than that's please pull my
hair there [ __ ]
sniffing his finger little taco ass give
you a break from you told you you're a
[ __ ] moose
the next time I meet a girl calls him
look for a year ago some pictures of a
[ __ ] her ass over firecrackers in it
today I got a Sunday 30 pictures in the
whole song tell her she's a dirty
[ __ ] [ __ ] nothing I can't wait for
you then she gave an order she told the
pineapples and berry
so his [ __ ] would be sweet swallow
but he went to rouse and bought the
pineapple yeah yeah I'm supposed to go
bless it orders you're supposed to wait
for the land give it that shot of juice
firm and then she'll fail you I got a
pineapple I don't [ __ ] know you
what do you not all what do you dull you
don't give them what they want you give
them what you want for the love of
[ __ ] Christ Senate next time you come
we'll have a story I'll try you won't
have he got his dick sucked for the
first time outside thirty years old
first time even a Boy Scout gets his
dick so that's true you know I think my
dick sucked killers 20 you know you see
just got a [ __ ] for the chick weather
yeah there it is outside yeah this guy's
lived the life and you don't understand
he's dirty he's only gonna be dirty once
and I've been telling them he won't eat
the airplane that's better take you on
the magic carpet right oh my god all I
can eat mushrooms I eat the fattest cap
because I know I'm gonna see some [ __ ]
I've also psychiatrists after will total
focus oh you ain't given the 48 hours no
more that's it 25 you don't need a
[ __ ] psychiatrist you need to live a
little
thank you we're great therapist which
one should I go to in LA
do you have one right in that round here
well these strip clubs are a little
different but I used to dance at
cheetahs and that's a great way it's
like a bikini bar though it's not
[Music]
probably one that's the one like it's
renin this is not happening
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I want to go to
real one answer Jesus I used to dance
there oh my god I used to push a lot of
weed out there I always liked me and
then my boss he would let me smoke weed
with the guys out there so I would like
I I could roll joints so I was selling
the lead then I would roll the weed in
the back and then I'll
smoked with him they'll tell me about
the problems and then they tip me and
then they come back and I always like
getting my coke in the daytime have any
problems at night it's not that I wanted
to snort my coke in the daytime it's
that I wanted to have it ready to snort
some when I got home there was no
misunderstanding a jacket pocket I take
it
snorted while I was taking a [ __ ] and
then make-believe nothing happened one
day called my dealer and he goes man if
you wanted I'm at a strip club hmm and
there was I lived in Hollywood close to
the one I lived on Schrader so they do
call me a jumbo a jumbo no no I just had
the women there like that yeah is that
true they're dead anyway and then
cheetahs is it's more like you know that
you get the dancers but then you could
hang out then we have a full bar you
could drink with them but no clothes
taking off I don't know about the
clothes being taken off because I went
there so my dealer tells me you gotta
meet me at cheetahs like where the [ __ ]
is cheetahs he goes you ever gonna walk
a poco is I know I know he goes before
that you're gonna hit cheetahs in those
days we used to always go to Acapulco
and get all you can eat lunch okay it's
not the one by where you do the Sycamore
tavern there's still water in Silver
Lake right and cheetahs is down on that
block now that figured I wanted it the
cheetahs one day I got my $60 for the
grand he's a black dude he sent at the
ball with three white chicks he's
personable as [ __ ] and he's talking to
them like do the whole thing I do the
exchange I give him a hug he's like stay
for a drink I'm feeling kinda creepy
[ __ ] 12 [ __ ] dark strip club like
Dracula's house
I look to the corner who's getting a lap
dance Bobby Lee like a [ __ ] with
titties in his face he's got two [ __ ]
Chinese fingers in her ass even though
he's Korean I don't know if they were
doing drink you shouldn't at that time
it was kind of kinky for lunch the
lunchtime crew at most clubs is supposed
to be a little dirtier they bend the
rules a little bit more than daytime
because you have less customers and they
want to make a little extra money so the
daytime they bend the rules just a
little great you leave your hand over
here just imagining how much money I'm
gonna waste if I'm going in the strip
club this is not waste you're gonna go
home with a nice chunk of [ __ ] silly
putty between your legs of sperm and
when you try to walk it you're gonna go
home with a life lesson for your little
vanilla girls I guess so I'm but that's
the thing I like even before we have sex
I only I tried vanilla Kylie I would
like to attract the girl who wanted to
get for you it's 40 for the bra at least
rip their panties it cost you a dollar
dollar store panties unless they say
they're Victoria see I've been given a
small 40 you know lick them monkey with
the panties on them eat the [ __ ] meat
milkshakes panties rip them in half and
just eat a piece of panties in front of
them to go crazy what you told okay well
I I guess I'm wrong you are [ __ ]
wrong
rip their problem so now after this the
can business now you've been opening up
a studio yes so ever webcam studio with
the other camp equipment on three
different stations and photography room
so I can help shoot content for them and
then I also have like a podcast room
that I'm hoping to start for helping
with the marketing got some weed weed
sponsors involved and just basically
give them a platform to promote and talk
about you know
they're doing their shows and porn stars
on they talk about their features that
are also doing cam shows I mean it's the
whole boob row so right now you still
strip on the wheels were you gonna go
strip Friday night when I saw you um no
well see I just got my tattoo done so it
was healing so last week I had like the
week off so I was just kami
yeah but and then you can't five nights
a week
uh yeah I'm gonna try try to do even
more so but when I'm not camming I'm
doing like snapchat premium content and
making little videos getting that ready
to get sold no I'm not the [ __ ] best
judge of character but you have it
really much together for a girl that's
29 why are you so different at 29 why
have you kept it together why have you
been shot yet really good parents I had
a really good like you know structure of
family that just you know taught me how
to do it but I also learned a lot from
people and I just I never tried to like
you know my when I told my parents
they're just like you know just don't
don't do drugs or get all crazy and
resort to that my father has you know he
has a dark past that I had to learn from
when I was younger so I just always knew
that that's not the path but I just I
want more I want to help my family I
want to help my girlfriends I want to
you know I just want to have a future
I'm getting 30 so it's like I'm gonna
have a career like I'm trying to build
an empire but I also want to help girls
there's girls turning 18 going into porn
and they don't know and even if they
want to do it that's fine but this is a
great way to make money and be
financially independent but just got
money coming from all different angles
and it gives you a lot of freedom Tom
can I tell you a story well no is it you
know I was raised Catholic like you
mm-hmm
and you know our program to think and
then one day a switch goes off and we go
crazy yeah like you know 18 years you've
never eaten somebody's [ __ ] you never
blown a guy an awesome one more you just
switch you just want to eat a [ __ ] [ __ ]
up a chick's ass that's what happens
with Catholicism but you also have that
inner thing that were raised with so I
always had that inner thing okay
at a young age being a Catholic you were
taught that a [ __ ] [ __ ] you had a
throw of rock at it okay you know Mary
Magdalene was stoned to death you know
even though she wiped Jesus's feet at
this time at that and all that [ __ ] so
part of your belief is a [ __ ] but I
still remember going on the 12th Avenue
as a kid where they had you know a
thousand hookers outside I'm looking at
him and always looking at him with a
weird perspective but something happened
my mother died and it made me go from
being the person that I wanted to be to
the person I didn't want to be I became
a thief did drugs and then when I was 19
I moved to Aspen Colorado and I always
had this thing about you know just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like you either a [ __ ] or
[ __ ] woman my but at that time I had
lived three years on my own and then I
remember living in Aspen maybe six
months and saying how much money comes
in there in the winter like you got like
my agent why he went skiing in Aspen a
few weeks ago he goes it's amazing the
price of the houses up there you know
4.6 million 13 million I go remember
that's one of the houses well you spend
13.6 million of the house that's not
your house in Aspen that should run the
house these guys gonna ask them without
their wives and I used to watch this Lea
as a young man at 19 I would sit at the
bars not like hang but I would watch
these older guys and then I became a
security guard at a hotel I would have
to pick people up drive them back there
since I was a little older that I was 21
and every night when I was driving back
whenever dominated I'm one of the guys
in the truck would say to me hey where's
the action and I was 21 and I didn't
know what to tell I didn't know what to
tell
well I swear to God if I picked three
sets of guys up even guys with wives as
I was picking up their luggage after I
checked them in the guy would come back
out go where did the action actually
looking for drugs and I would never in
those days these are people that are
coming and they could be the age Wow
so how he's playing the dummy the drugs
but they would ask me where's not
playing so much can I get a woman
everybody was looking for a woman
everybody was looking for a woman and
then I got to the point one they'd
started giving me prizes it's no mess I
was I was doing this in Snowmass mill
it's not even Aspen you know I would see
the guys in the hotel they're gonna come
in what you find now for me do you know
any bronze I could call and I was an
[ __ ] guys I didn't know nothing I was
like the worst bellman in the world call
a hooker for you is [ __ ] I don't know
nobody let her forget sitting there one
day going you know let's be honest let's
stop being a [ __ ] hypocrite if I was
a 21 year old girl and I look like you
establish myself lightly well I don't
think that I don't know if there's a
strip club can you look it up strip
clubs in Aspen I don't know if there is
any so you'd have to work very
discreetly and then you look up and
they'll look up escorts an aspect yeah
you'd have to work actually everywhere
listen yeah but I made a decision
Wow there's actually an article that
says forget Vegas take the bachelor
party to Aspen there you go and I said
to myself if I'm a woman if I was a
woman right now my mom was dead and I
had a
body like that girl right there like you
or face like yours I would make a plan I
let my 21 to 25 I'm gonna go to Aston
from November to March 15 take all that
far on the money all that Texas oil
money you know you can review the call
yourself 500 enamel oh yeah three and
nine times that times five three weeks a
month will exclude the month that you
have the [ __ ] visitor three weeks a
month for four months you put that in
the bank you go back to where you're
from at the end of the winter resort and
maybe dancing vein pick up if you take
that money for five years and then one
day just disappear hmm change your pl
change your name disappear nobody knows
your past I'm not talking about born I'm
talking about taking guys for their
[ __ ] though you know exactly what I'm
talking about like Sharon Stone and
casino guy comes into town 20 large four
days actually they don't have a strip
club though no there's nothing business
there's only one thing I even on Yelp
this is the Denver party strippers
yesterday I have to fly to Denver so I
mean that's that's I would do it if I
was a woman no responsibilities and a
twelve body you're gonna [ __ ] twenty
guys anyway then they're gonna waste
your time Wow take you on dates try to
do dumb [ __ ] to you what's the
difference you put your feelings aside
and I know you're gonna enjoy but you
have a daughter I'm telling you that if
a woman has a man without a plan is not
a man and a woman without a plan is not
a man if a woman says I'm giving myself
four years to pull down 250,000 to
300,000 toward you to that cash 20,000
that tax-free that they're giving you
cash in a bedroom for two stalkers a
pretty girl asset that's a thousand our
yeah those guys gonna take you for ten
hours
how much did it cost now I don't think
you do it very yeah I mean something
like that no and I'll do it straight up
but I mean you even get paid to be a
companion and go out for dinner and
dreams I've gotten hit up on the strip
in Vegas how much they charge the
companions in Vegas it could be anything
it could be like 1,500 3 K 5 K I mean it
all depends on the girl and whatever but
if you're smart and you know you could
really work it out I mean it's very
lucrative but um you know you just do
you got to be in control
I'm not college educated you have a
little bit of Street knowledge
you know you know intelligent
conversations but then just you don't
act like a train wreck like you know
drugs no booze if you're professional a
[ __ ] professional white girl don't do
drugs
those the doctor every week checks a
monkey out changes the oh yeah you know
let's uh you know three four regulars
think about just in LA alone look I read
that book my motya you never work in
this town again and Micah hooker who
wrote a [ __ ] book about you know she
was a celebrity hooker Don Henley this
producer that actor and she just wrote
seven chapters about 700 John's and the
money she was making and it's she said
she used to go to Don Henley's house and
even be alive five grand for two hours
and she would bend over in front of a
fireplace with three other girls mmm and
he would just sit there do a line of
coke go over [ __ ] for two minutes and
go sit back down and get up and [ __ ] the
other one for two minutes you just told
me about a story about a guy a white guy
I am putting mess up people's asses oh
no you're talking about no yoga sparrows
he's talking about the the Democratic
donor who you didn't hear about that
oh then this isn't strictly this is he's
going around finding and finding
homeless black guys that are gay and
that he like he like his thing as he
likes to shoot him up with meth and to
to him to have died and like the path
like year
it's it's in West Hollywood it's
terrible that this is what that's it
more like that's the dark side of it I
was not talking about the guy who spent
$200 on a can model and then he killed
his bears because you took all their
money sexuality you know it makes people
feel people creepy on the street strip
club sometimes ya know oh I'm tough I'm
like there's no guy who can't walk in
there and think he's gonna trick me or
tell me something new I've heard it I've
you know and it's cool but it's just
it's just about having a good time
maybe they give you a counterfeit money
oh no they gave it like another girl
counterfeit money but never me I mean
and I'm pretty like hardcore on that but
no never got that chuckle you hundreds
oh yeah really gonna have a light like
like a little light that you can put on
it I mean go to the bank and it what's
your future what do you see my future 29
I would like to have a studio where I'm
helping girls and um you know really
doing it but my future is I want to put
events together with this platform of
all these girls take them out of just
camming um you know avian I did it and
we're kami live at the event there's
just a simple convention but it really
opens your eyes to like okay if I could
do this at some whatever convention I
could do this at a party like I could
throw the party and have live can
stations that people watch the girls
have the weed company girls smoke and
live like on there and it's just it's a
party because these viewers that's what
they want they want a little party on
the internet because they're married or
they're kind of nerdy they can't even
walk into a strip club they're from all
over the world they you know there's a
lot of possibilities with this and I
want it I want to innovate this [ __ ]
like what I've done at festivals this
can totally be done here but on a
smaller scale and just bring all these
hot sexy bad
to make money everything for sale so the
strip club business is still booming his
Vegas booming not as good as it was you
know years ago because there wasn't this
instant gratification there wasn't it
social media and you know dating sites
and apps where people can connect with
hot girls you kind of that's what guys
went to to meet the hot girls now it's
like guys come in there and it's like
all I don't want to you know they try to
play hard-to-get or they're [ __ ] but
that's like cold for them to say that
they like us and they want us to stick
when I said get the [ __ ] out of here
supposed to be a gentlemen's club ain't
no gentleman in there but you know
there's 200 girls in the floor so that's
a lot of competition but there's a lot
of hot girls it's like hey why don't
even deal with the stress like come over
here help you make money it's easy like
camming you don't touch anybody you
don't have to be around anybody and you
can really do whatever you want
possibilities are I'm not doing porn
online when did you quit before I quit
porn I could've had a fallout with my
agency and it just wasn't working out
and I was signed to like a three-year
contract but I didn't get any work and
there was a fight I could have you know
got a lawyer and kept going but I just
saw the Kami world and I was like you
know what I'm like [ __ ] doing this I
want to be behind the camera I want to
help girls you know really learn no
one's training girls and I could
literally walk any girl doesn't matter
if she's a porn star I can walk her
she'll train at all aspects as well as
I've learned the software I've been
testing it on myself I can walk a girl
through every hurdle she's gonna go
through but I'm just like I'll speed
them up get them Cammy with me but you
can do fun [ __ ] like every guy when you
have more than most like one girl on cam
it really attracts a lot of people but
yeah it's just have fun it's like yo
[ __ ] being in these dirtier strip clubs
I mean you know you can go there and
still hustle but on the weekdays
like the hustle hell yeah you got
regulars ah yes I do I have lots of
people that come see me for years
really oh man I'm just fun I mean but I
just call them the whole thing they call
me I mean I'm there and I'm just I stay
consistent and stuff but sometimes I'm
spending a lot of time in my studio
because I'm trying to transition and and
stuff but I still I still love it it's
still fun it's a rush listen I was a
thief the world works when I did it that
girl for four years even though we had
disagreements about a lot of things
after we broke up
the truth of the matter is I always have
to think about it because she got me she
was the one that said let's go to la la
you know I had a deal with CBS she's
like this is a good move for you I'll go
down there and strip whatever the [ __ ]
but it was really weird
that I learned the whole of the world of
the strip club like I learned like
that's what you just wanted to a strip
club got a dancing you went home and
then she was telling me no no you gotta
text these [ __ ] mom and tell
him I'm danced at I'm at 9:00 bring to
all hours and you have 20 of them on
rotation she was telling me stories that
were that made me feel bad because she
was kind of she was doing something that
I had done years earlier which was
deceit people in a way like outside of
the club oops
inside the club and said okay you know
is very deceitful it was you know how
you doing baby I really care about you
what's going on you talk to them you saw
this soft spot
you saw the vulnerability and you attack
them yet I'm saying so I'd say you work
Tuesdays Thursdays and Fridays days you
have different guys that come along
those days they're expecting this
you know it's like my mom I had a bar
and she wouldn't let bartenders tell the
customers that they had boyfriends the
first time I see a boyfriend at the bar
you find well I want them to have an
image that they always have a chance of
winning you over once a guy finds out
you got a boyfriend
there's no end that's it I'm not gonna
get with her even though some guys are
turned down by that that's the other
package you could say to them I got a
boyfriend win me over [ __ ] I'm like yo
I got a boyfriend like so I'm not gonna
text you on the weekend you want to see
me you'll come to this strip club and we
do what we do then you go back to your
life and then you just you know cut and
they're okay with that at least they
could get some I've had guys would be
like gonna be the side guy like the side
chick I'm just like wow
but it's the belief that yeah you and I
are gonna get married and have kids
off into the sunset and you have to keep
that dream alive that takes them like
nine weeks to realize that you're taking
them for everything you don't show up in
Denny's for the same time we had daddy's
you know I'm saying like it's like this
[ __ ] especially when you have a
traffic jam and you got one guy coming
in when you're still dealing with
another guy and then they're like way
more you know I'm paying for full
attention and like my eight o'clock CEO
so it's a shuttle bleep yeah but
sometimes I mean you know it's really
funny but you just keep going and half
the time they always come back they try
to act like it never happened and what
we can bring but it's so ridiculous oh
really what but you play around you're
like oh yeah didn't really we're willing
what you want to know something you
should be come in earlier with more
money and then you know I can't cancel
me and it's weird because they either
just got a relationship
there's a problem all kinds of if you
were me and you want to tell me why your
problems hell no you pay me then you
know I'll listen to you and and whatever
but it's just like are you [ __ ]
serious like I'm I live a great life and
I'm happy I'm not poor my problems on to
you so it's like you want meets you want
to bore you want to kill my sunshine
with your depression and in a sense you
know like say that for your girlfriend
otherwise pay me some racks and yo I'll
take your problems and we'll [ __ ] have
a great ass time you won't even remember
what you were whining about let me ask
you this give a bit dancing you see a
guy that you look at me like to fall in
love with this guy have you ever had
that I mean it's not like you might
think it he's twice dirty and then you
know you see him you observe him with
the other girls and then you observe him
how he is with you but they always
[ __ ] shoot their own foot like they
killed that moment and it you know no
they need to stay a customer you're very
controlled you're very uh I've hadn't
learned from a lot of mistake so now
it's like drugs
who me yeah no I mean I party but I'm
I'm very good at doing it like I do it
occasionally I don't do not look healthy
like yep this morning you will awake at
7:00 I wake up really early I try to you
know I've been programming myself to get
off the Vegas funk of like you know
strippers we tend to like sleep in
really late so I've been programming
myself to like wake up during the week
while you're in LA there's no stripper
no I don't dance at any club so here I
came at my my place but otherwise like I
do photo shoots or you know I link with
people that do a lot of networking I'm
really involved in a lot of stuff so
like I you know I am trying to do
camming
like I got a social life and you know
I'm doing a lot of big things that I
want to help girls and I'm really
involved in the social media - that's a
really big important thing to use when
you have the family structure you look
healthy I mean you mentally sound what
made you make the decision usually a
girl comes in here
I haven't had yeah we have not had a
point anything else since the guy who
all the Buddy Tommy I don't know much
about it so why would I bring somebody I
don't know much about the porn world
they would like I don't know kitty cat
like two weeks ago I was at the Comedy
Store and some girl came by me with big
tits and she goes you were great tonight
and some guy hit me in the chest you
know that is that's [ __ ] the amazing
Tami she kills rabbits with a [ __ ]
yourself [ __ ] and I'm like I don't know
no nobody they're like come on you don't
know so now I gotta get in the car
feeling like an old man and feeling like
I'm a [ __ ] half a [ __ ] cuz I don't
even watch one no who's happening in the
porn world no more you know I know I
hear Kira because you guys told me about
that and this does a podcast red van I
know the chick that got beat up by
[ __ ] Christie Mac I don't know her
personally but I know she is she is
going just I looked at her footage it
was terrible into it
I don't know the money behind it but you
just know the guy who likes porn I don't
know five or six years ago I just like I
used to watch porn stars but now even on
like the porn websites I'll just go and
look at the amateur stuff and I was
really into one of the camp sites for
for a while I'm cheap so I didn't I
didn't pay for it so that's why I
stopped doing it yeah I know I'm sorry
uh but I don't you think don't you think
more people now probably are into
amateur than porn stars very much so and
really camming is kind of taking over
and there's a lot I'm making a lot of
money but they have the flexibility to
shoot their own content of like whatever
the
you own it that's it you know do
different you could get cakes and you
could sit on it smash it with your ass
like you could do just about how about
then we got a check to put harassing
Kate you just said the man just mother
father do anything burnt your birthday
can a few animals like a half a cosby
pill smell the cake we will let you go
and we'll put a cake in there as I'm
sitting here right your plan I don't
give a [ __ ] ye Zi can still pull it over
guys I'm like Ronda Rousey with the arm
even though you know it's coming I still
gets it when you smell the cake I don't
care we put the cake deep in there and
sort it blows like a cork in you yeah
people would pay and I know you know
what I don't want it at this point my
live only don't want ten points give it
to the girl production deal right now
let's set a date the pay-per-view they
want to guaranteed two million dollar to
who want to see there's no two million I
don't want to get we need to collab with
some other fart apart any of farts and
you will headline
yeah sure with a 400-pound black chick
for sure face for two million I'll do it
officiate n pork chops so you got a
barbecue with some Cosby dusted it and
the [ __ ] five base your Pat's out and
a little blood in your face for you man
no that poster looks like and now the
next time it's seen this time who's on
the undercard no please you're gonna get
that the UFC card it's like a UFC car
there yeah but they fight like twice a
year mom so you do about six or seven
and then the New Year's Eve card is the
one with a fat she comes in they drop
her off by a tow truck you know I'm
saying that she's got taking her I got a
blow job at least not with the money
you're gonna make
pay-per-view New Year's Eve nineteen
five a piece you have no idea we could
do eight people are gonna buy eight [ __ ]
eight people the first [ __ ] minute
one sale the pre-sale what are you
[ __ ] nuts or what she's got ideas I
got ideas I like you with paints that's
happened I guess she farts don't blood
blood Island what about it we sit you
down
sure yeah we just drove you before that
you when you're handcuffed and whip you
whip you know I don't want I don't like
pain once you're handcuffed how do you
know blindfold you what do you mean how
do I know I don't like ah this is this
kind of how what percentage of people
are into that stuff it's a very small
percentage oh yeah oh yeah these are
like doctor lawyer very highly
intelligent people who are into this
into the camp's into I'm fetish but yes
what do you mean by first idea she could
be feed it could be stockings it could
be latex outfits um I thought it goes on
I mean there's nylon there's about a
fetish for everything smoking and
exhaling that's a big fetish I do a lot
of like small penis humiliation and jerk
off instructions instruction a guy comes
to your house and you teach you know so
I'm cam you'll get a session and from
what it is so they can pay extra for me
to open their cam to actually watch
their dick and basically I just dressed
hot as [ __ ] and I just tell them how
disgusting and pitiful their dicks are
and then I teach them like oh yeah
you can't even you don't even know your
owners manual like let me show you how
to do it and they kind of get turned on
from that but yeah it's great money no
clothes getting taken off and it's
really like it's it's the tone of your
voice it's your body language it's how
you're looking at them and you got to be
like how does [ __ ] that they're just
like oh I don't even care she's
insulting me this is hot
it's a whole new world are you looking
for a new model all the time
this guy right here my dungeon sex when
it's ready content so we can do a little
I don't like the pain stuff make your
mother proud
we can make my mother proud my mom with
this only so it's not you you're never
left in the pain you get rewarded what's
a little leisure so you got a [ __ ]
that's on that yeah well look no you
need to not say what you want and you
just gotta go with the flow let's see
why yeah this is enough I'm - I'm worse
enemy you know get paid to be though
it's all about consensual 'ti you never
do anything yeah this is not consensual
for me I'm glad some people like it but
I don't want to get I don't know people
I have I think bad things about myself
all right I don't want someone and say
no no thank you give me two edibles and
made me think of all this stuff I don't
know yeah you do do you want someone to
tell you your piece of [ __ ] like that I
already know it it's mostly I mean I
would love I would totally be into other
stuff like sexual stuff like what like
normal sex stuff what's normal sex
[ __ ] regular psych maybe for me okay
I mean I'm no Mick Jagger right look at
yourself in the mirror
yes no nobody was a second thing the eye
socket the Chum milkshake milkshake
didn't you but you didn't put in a mouth
like for yeah because I believe people
when they say don't
I'm not gonna shove it in their mouth
I'll try it now being shoved in our
mouth I'm people would they say they
mean tell me who the girl sitting here
for [ __ ] seven years
that's who says will not lie until you
do what [ __ ] girl
the girls are slept with know when
you're eating their monkey you start
singing I'm letting you walk around you
past that guard and you you when they
stand and they look at you addicted wait
three inches from their mouth obviously
you're not going to check that
temperature mmm
you have to promote Italy you just can't
ask them you have to keep finger them
and put a pinkie in their [ __ ] all
right you nuts
oh Jesus okay but then you never ask
yourself do I want my nuts in my mouth
when I was 25 yeah I was a sexy Savage
now I don't want my nuts in nobody's
mouth it's disgusting
well I don't know somebody yeah this is
why I said to you they told her the
party's over
you gotta go do it now okay I'll try
them down maybe please call milkshake
today give her a second no she wants me
to be her boyfriend I don't wanna tell
us what did they do tell her whatever
you want no I thought about and I want
to be a boy for them to come down there
[ __ ] out a five-acre go and then if she
calls you look you got it keep it
pushing and then every time where do you
keep what does that mean keep let's
gonna go back to life and do what you do
but you're not committing well that's
what you gotta get them Craven your dick
you're not crazy
thank you craving your dick they're
gonna go get dick from somebody else
well my week is mom can I go you gotta
keep on the string all day tell you
can't wait to suck her ass you can't
wait to light a [ __ ] on fire I can't
say those crotchless pain every time I
get ready to face on shadow
tell them you don't know what it's like
humiliate me that we have a certain
belief here at the church and constantly
breaks dish I constantly break if
there's any woman out there please if
I'm
tell me I'm wrong but this not every
woman can can think this like is that
this is how this is how people are going
to gentlemen like me to like this I got
a bikini [ __ ] after I got the piggy
yeah anything goes
so you walk around you continue
fingering uh she's like moaning huh and
you drop your dick in them oh okay and
then the girls that I've been with who I
say who do that and they're like oh I
don't like when you come in my mouth how
do I continue to do it I'm just coming
in I like it this is how much you make
me feel all right I need to get in their
head you need that you never came to
that girl's mouth you said you didn't
like it
who gives a [ __ ] what they don't like
their car I guarantee and five-year four
years you were with it I could count on
one hand how they pick something she
gave no I'm sure that I guarantee she to
give you more than ten well you're wrong
no guarantee she gave you one [ __ ]
what are you doing are you like licking
her [ __ ] oh yeah you like [ __ ] her
in like public places public well I've
never done it I've never done it but I
wouldn't be against that sure I told you
either in the car that's as public as
I've gotten
- Paula broad wanted you to rip it she
had glasses I told him how many times
take the glasses off Rome on the wall if
you could sleep and then [ __ ] that
turns women on they can't see oh yeah he
thinks you're Brad Pitt put a [ __ ]
rug on your head they don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm saying these are things
you [ __ ] up I've been telling you you
[ __ ] up Liv I told you this is day one
don't even tie her up put firecrackers
in her ass she's got those offense feet
you didn't do know these things you want
to watch her getting her outfits to wear
so she can do nothing there you go
that's a craving day he never came home
with handcuffs you never know what I did
I'm like oh I know what you did I don't
know what you did nothing you watch
oranges
purple yeah I would call you that's what
you do he couldn't even watch that goes
without it no you don't do that the
relationship you watch it then you tell
out loud and watch that I waited how
would I do that because I have to watch
it twice you're a man yes are you a
married a [ __ ]
I want so what being a man is watching a
TV show being a man is something across
the [ __ ] board from A to Z all right
we'll try putting your balls on the
table I like my balls on the table
that's fine you don't put them on the
table okay let's let's try it put that
there in your piece at least sign on
Twitter let me know how can we find you
huggy the young beautiful men find this
bacon fanatic queen on Twitter and onyx
muse xxx all right my Instagram yeah the
camming all that on Instagram I'm onyx
commune 777 but if you want that free
goes yes yes free those they're all free
I'll tell you about my premium stuff and
my cam shows I usually promote a lot of
before I go on and and then I have my
regular Instagram for just like my
dancing and stuff don't move monster
said man you're very interesting thank
you very beautiful I'm sorry I didn't
know more about this world you know I
really wanted to come here to be like
you know you need like a personal like
blunt roller blunt roller the bowl
Packer like somebody who's like I always
see like nobody like guy sit ready no
you deserve juice me out it's like me
sending you for coffee yourself I can
live have this is when people have this
system oh no not like that
that's an embarrassing thing I wish I
had money to hire a professional joint
role like most people want a butler
I would I want two things if I had that
much money I would get it
I gotta have a rickshaw just run around
with me like this morning I would have
them taken it all over the house a good
home
rickshaw I'm the fall fighter that's
always been my fantasy some [ __ ] guy
just run and I have to get a new one
every time they'll die don't have to be
high they got these in trafficking don't
they bring up moving with some other cut
you and Robert Kraft are gonna be in the
same cell why they blaming how no no I
just want to know why is he in trouble
for human traffic cuz they bring people
in from China who wasn't at the doin ma
just walk them to get his dick sucked
dat have a passport because it doesn't
matter that what matters is the
prostitution but the reason why people
get upset is because they're from like
their slaves who gives a [ __ ] whether
it's a chick with a passport or a chick
without a passport it's a little blow
job right then that's the part that he
got arrested for he didn't get arrested
for the human trafficking right they're
just saying that those places are bad
because of the human trafficking but
even he just got arrested like a normal
prostitute where I'm going next week is
a capital human trafficking with that
Houston Texas oh [ __ ] that's where they
have ice well I saw the TV show I was
just cuz I never even really the only
people in the Asian when I saw in
Houston you know I haven't been there in
a long time I like when I used to gonna
have to change the dumpling palace does
the only Chinese people I know and also
I'm watching the show about like that
drugs Inc the other one they have and G
whatever and the [ __ ] hub of it is
Houston Chinese girls they suck your
dick crying
then listen fingers is [ __ ] the Yakuza
cuts that the hose off and [ __ ] if you
don't send money to the family's
eminence
that's very terrible I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm not taking you from your
family your country now that be Isis
Brian the kiss of death yet the reason
for my husband's and a [ __ ] kid now
you come over here with an Isis kid why
would you do that
what type of filthy [ __ ] animal are
you that you're raised in the United
States give good dick Thomas that live
in the wind
I like humming ah but it's I mean you so
much abilities the American woman but
she's craving like cystic uh yeah well
it's not that good much it has to be
great
no she comes back with a little ices
baby well know that I like the letter I
know it's [ __ ] rub down with
gunpowder the kids ready to go he's a
fourth of July [ __ ] he's a
firecracker they don't know it I'm happy
you came on educated that's today I
gotta fight it and pleasure meeting you
man well your manager was very nice and
he was very sweet he talked you up you
hit me up that night it was very nice to
joint in the downhill when I do that
good I thought it was okay like I hope
it's not okay give it to somebody or
throw it away and it will nice always it
joint I just what happened was you had a
whole joint
but you didn't seal it yeah but just the
thought somebody gave me a [ __ ] ash
pan you don't fry daddy to smoke all day
oh really
well you know I didn't smoke till maybe
130 that morning before we order room
service
I didn't smoke all day like I smoke to
vapor do you ever smoke like before you
do your shows I smoke all day by 8
o'clock the smoke don't even work no
more yeah I smoke a whole joint that's
what he's saying it's so weird that he
didn't smoke for 18 hours what I do is I
smoke a pipe I smoke a bong here I smoke
a pipe at the house and I smoke joints
on the road to mix it up to keep my
lungs confused never get used to one
[ __ ] thing I'm saying you can't you
got to mix it up a little bit so when I
go on the Royal I I can't bring a pipe
through Airlines it stinks you know what
I'm gonna travel with a [ __ ] bomb so
I just wanna join and I really smoke a
joint in the morning I am my hotel rooms
I don't smoke in the hotel room I go for
a walk around the neighborhood and then
when I go to the show if there's two
shows up bring three joints
if there's one shop bring two joints
these are great choice we great and I
know how to roll them enroll already
[ __ ] is I think my best performances
when I just smoke pot and go get giggly
and I get stupid that's the best like
the other night yeah I like that [ __ ] I
was doing the animals on stage they just
it's a 50-50 toss-up I like just smoking
pot that's how I found you like somebody
told me about your show and I'm like
who's uncle Joey and then you were like
smoking and joining or like you know you
ain't smoked up by two o'clock can we
[ __ ] talk - no you gotta get high
early in the morning to get it out of
the way the last two mornings
yeah the morning I got up at 5:00 by
4:30 by myself to be because I want the
better ten something and I got up before
something and I put my head back down
finally I pop my head up I look at the
monitor I know Terry what the [ __ ] is
going on and mercy had the lights out of
that room reading a book out loud
so which is all God hurts my mother was
in there like my mother was furious
my god I put a [ __ ] robot like I just
see a tear ass in there let her grunty
turn the light off and go back to bed
and then we laid down for like 10
minutes and you could still hear and my
wife got up like oh you know what I got
up and what if the Mercy's real I go
what's going on Vasia goes nothing
you want to go watch some TV she goes
yeah daddy let's go
my wife saw she's like what the [ __ ] are
you guys doing out at 5:00 in the
morning
like I can't sleep I don't need it
tonight so we watched a little [ __ ]
TV and I took of the school and it was
[ __ ] try this last this morning it
happened again so my wife is pissed
walking around the house like don't do
this no more she can't get into the
habit of getting up at 5:00 and we just
sit there I drink coffee she watches
duck tails no I asked a stupid [ __ ]
questions and she looks at me like that
again
what do you say what's the cousin's name
Oh
tormenta from every [ __ ] direction I
have to toughen her up so that's great
she's gonna get eaten alive yes yes
you always have an open invite if you
ever do any of your events or you want
to do a cam thing oh yeah I always have
a lot of advice you're very intelligent
you're beautiful I like what you're
doing today yeah thank you very much for
coming out thank you a great time all
right I thought well I think Dom's onyx
Muse onyx muse she's a very lovely lady
I really enjoyed having her on I want to
thank my man the [ __ ] I want to
thank you guys do not forget Saturday
and Friday later already sold out in
Houston Texas
so you got two [ __ ] options
Thursday or [ __ ] Friday so listen
that's all you got left don't tell me
then get tickets Joey I didn't know if
you don't know now you know Saturday is
sold out and Friday [ __ ] later sold
out Thursday is still available couple
tickets left and [ __ ] Friday is it
early there's a ton of tickets left you
guys must have a [ __ ] rocket game or
something like that don't wanna don't
come to me crying [ __ ] late all right
I'm letting you know right now all right
all I got for you guys this month is
Houston
the Irvine improv Houston improv that's
it that's all I got
go to improv calm go to Houston and then
click on and get your tickets they don't
hit me back and go they $150 for your
tickets it's double who the [ __ ] told
you to go to [ __ ] stop up no I tell
you go and then prob calm compress in
Houston and they'll give me the [ __ ]
thing you get two tickets nice and
[ __ ] cheap 28 something 50 25 on
Thursday night all right so now you know
now you know how you do it but before I
go the church is brought to you by zip
recruiter let me tell you some you know
our list to find the right people look
how I've been stuck with leave for seven
years what do you think ha ha ha I love
this [ __ ] kid anyway
zipper cooler makes it easy for you to
hire okay hiring used to be hard
multiple job sites tax or resume a
confusing review process
but today iron can be easy and you can
go to one place to get it done zip
recruiter dot-com
Church okay zip recruiter sends you a
job over a hundred of the web's leading
job boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful Mack matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job as the application comes in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates so you
never miss a great match right or wrong
zip recruit is effective 80% of the
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
you understand me like I said in the
beginning of the show whether your
business is small or large you want the
best people available and right now the
church family could try zip recruiter
for free gratis free go to zip recruiter
comm slash church again
zip recruiter calm slash Church si-hu
rch zip recruiter comm slash shirts the
church is also brought to you by listen
to me one time I asked my wife to shave
my nutsack and I was so [ __ ] nervous
okay
I don't like head down there now that
I'm gonna get dry and brittle at the end
I'm an old man you know I'm saying
that's why I'm with manscaped Uncle Joe
is here to tell you this is the way to
go you're not to suffer no more worry
about your balls missing worry about
somebody pulling a bobbin on your you're
walking around with a half a dick that's
my [ __ ] fantasy somebody cut in half
your dick off you don't need this [ __ ]
but with a lawn mower point-to-point all
the handheld razor with the skid safe
technology come on so it won't Nick or
snag your nutsack cuz let me tell you
some you need those nut sacs you got to
put them in people's mouths this bad boy
will leave you nice clean smooth and
anxiety [ __ ] free plus it's
rechargeable and easy to hold so you can
get into all those [ __ ] nooks and
crannies under your [ __ ] you know
that little pubic can it sticks on your
[ __ ] that whole [ __ ] that stink
festival between your nutsack and your
[ __ ]
all that [ __ ] hat boom it comes off
and they got a classic safety razor
called you ready for this one the plow
that'll give you a smooth shave without
the bumps and you know what they say
you
you trim the hedges the tree looks
taller so what the [ __ ] are you waiting
for you filthy [ __ ] animals go to
manscape dot-com you can get everything
you need to make your ball shine and
keep your dick looking [ __ ] good you
don't want to end up looking like my
[ __ ] dick looks like you got hit in
the head with 20 [ __ ] hammers and
they got plucked and more wipe they got
a special nice little ball wipe nation
[ __ ] nutsack nice and minty fresh
understand me
have this is the first time you've
considered manscaping they got a deal
for you they got the perfect package
comes with a lawnmower and the plow plus
a crop Reserve especially formulated
anti shafting deodorant so your balls
don't stink you need that li you need
that too and the Reviver a sprint that
tones and refreshes your nutsack ooh to
keep it cool that's the one I use the
Reviver and my nut sacs were red for the
rest of the [ __ ] night it felt like
somebody was balancing my nut saying you
know you've steals Chinese people with
those balls man same thing that's what
it felt like somebody was jiggling my
nuts all night so I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna take care of the
church I'm gonna get you 20% off your
first order when you use promo code
Church CH you are CH at manscape tom
again that's manscape tom and if you
order the perfect package they're also
throw in a free travel bag which i have
when you use promo code church again
promo code church that's manscape calm
and use promo code church for 20% off
your first order wash your nutsack
[ __ ] don't walk around on why
don't I have a date cuz your [ __ ]
dick smells like a camel
no more manscape doc tom promo code
church on the way out I want to thank
the prakruti
I want to thank [ __ ] manscape com I
want to thank Domo aka onyx muse but
most importantly I want to thank the
church family for always being there for
me for understanding where the [ __ ]
coming from me he understand me I want
to take the [ __ ] Jew killer here the
Christ killer and I want to thank you
guys for being a family I'll see you
next weekend Tammy [ __ ] Winkler be
there would be spooky Bobby's sharing
ain't coming but he's coming to [ __ ]
Dallas and San
tonio we got the whole crew coming so
I'll see you [ __ ] in the
Houston Texas next weekend
stay black uncle Joey loves you check
this [ __ ] to me Lee